[Music]
[Applause]
now this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers not one
winner we don't make mistakes well
tonight a fan with the YouTube username
ethan b612 thinks that he found a
mistake he says it happened recently in
a segment with actor John Krasinski by
Counting fan corruption here hears you
talking to John Krasinski a while ago
about meeting the president president
the air around you changes it becomes
really intense it's crazy how come you
and Grover Cleveland I meant Grover
Cleveland
his sideburns are they alright Conan
here's a picture of Grover Cleveland no
sideburns pocket mustache but no
sideburns I think you're probably
thinking about Chester a Arthur nice try
though
now I know when you're depressed you
know you and you're sending a message
out to the world but I suggest you put
on something other than a bad yeah I'm
sorry Ethan b612 but in fact I was
talking about Grover Cleveland and he
did have sideburns don't believe me then
take a look at this incredibly rare
never-before-seen footage come on
never-before-seen footage from the
Library of Congress filmed on May 5th
1886 footage of President Grover
Cleveland at the barbershop getting his
sideburns trimmed what'll it be mr.
president just trim the sideburns a
little so amazing that's like 40 years
before talkies and yet they still had
synchronous sound I'm getting a Chinese
you in here in a second shut your trap
sorry so the challenge still stands if
if you think you've spotted if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
report it at team koco.com
/ how I found an error we will sort it
out here on the air let's see if you got
what it takes to make Chuck meat out of
the maestro